I asked the police the amount of blood
you saw in Stephanie's car do you
believe that she is now dead
[Music]
found a skull and it was definitely
human
I need to know the person who was
responsible for my mother's death
I was expecting that case to be solved
within the first week but it didn't
happen
my co-workers were reading how the
Golden State killer case had been solved
through genealogy they're solving all
these old cases don't you think they
could do that
tape is like a DNA Gold Mine this is the
biggest lead we've had since 1995.
I see him light a cigarette
that's our sample we got the shock of
Our Lives we have found his DNA on some
old evidence from way back in the 70s
the fingernails great things it was a
match
with today's technology the police are
going to come knocking okay years from
now but
they'll come
[Music]